okay thank you I'm here to talk about
intake which is funded by anaconda but
is fully open source and open to all
most of you will not have used it before
it's new and I'm here to encourage you
to try it and make your feedback known
requests conversation all welcome and
yeah get involved so to start off I
expect there are quite a few data
scientists here but even if you aren't
you've probably come across code that
looks like this you've probably written
code that looks like this for those that
don't know all that this code cell is
doing is loading you see that pointer
yes okay three particular CSV files and
it's using pandas to stitch them into a
single data frame and the point of the
code cell is that you want to create
this data frame so that then you can go
off and do your analysis on that and the
job that you're doing
is that analysis so everything that's in
this code this cell is necessary but not
very interesting now I'm going to take
you through a few opinions that
different people might have about a code
cell that looks like this but first I
just want to ask you who has written
something that looks like this in the
past and that is nearly everybody I'd
say a good 80% of people put their hands
up and the rest of you may be a little
bit shy so first opinion this person I'm
calling the data user that is the one
that is actually going to execute this
and wants to do something with the data
frame that it produces by the way I'm
using data frame and CSVs is very common
there's lots of other types of data that
you might be wanting to load and lots of
well another set of different outputs
that you might consider like a raisin
things I'll just keep to the simple case
for now so the data user had to write
this probably and they don't want to
ever have to do this all they want
to have the data frame and do things
with the data frame that is their job
secondly there is nothing in this Kotel
that actually tells you what this data
is you have some file names you have
some URL you have some other stuff that
is necessary but you don't know if this
is the right thing if you're coming back
to this code in the future you don't
really know what this was for sure you
can comment you can keep extra
information around but it's not inherent
in what you're doing so that's a real
problem figuring out which data set you
need to do the particular task that you
want to do second person is the one that
has actually put these files into place
they realize that somebody is using
files that are not actually the current
best data that they should be using
there's been a new update and they need
to let the user know that this has
happened somehow secondly maybe it's not
CSV anymore maybe it's not stored at
this HTTP endpoint anymore lots of
things can have changed and may be very
good reasons for why those things have
changed in every case the person who's
managing how the data gets into the
system needs to have a way to tell the
user that this has happened so in alert
and needs to have a way of getting the
user to be able to get at this data
which is now in a different format in a
different storage location that's all
painful stuff thirdly if you have an IT
department at your organization they
would be very angry about you including
your credentials directly in your code
you should never do that this is a
notebook you can mess around with
notebooks treat them as sandbox no
shouldn't do that you should certainly
never check it into your version control
so there's that part and then actually
the most common problem would code like
this is that it tends to be copied and
pasted from one person to the other hey
where's that thing that gets me the data
that I need to do my job
oh here it is copy and paste that it
will work this is very antithesis to
what IT security and monitoring is about
and then finally dev which is what I
count myself as what if now the new data
format because let's say your data
production engine switched from some
logging thing to Kafka say now it's
coming in and Avro pandas doesn't read
avarice of what you do somebody's going
to have to write some code even more so
if it's actually on a different storage
system somebody needs to go and stitch
all these different things together and
that's a pain then they have to get this
code again to the user the user is
probably not the one that's writing that
code they maybe maybe not there's quite
a tangle of things going on here and all
of this is what intake is aimed at
solving so in the intake world that code
cell looks something like this as an
example you have some file in this case
which includes a catalog definition in
there it tells you what your datasets
are and how to read them so that the
user all they do is reference a catalog
and then they do dot read and there's
your data frame so all of the stuff that
you had before is now abstracted away
it's it's hidden in a definition and the
user just you there's this one liner to
get their data out I will show you what
these things look like in a moment but
our first note to say the Yamal
definition is only one possible way that
you can encode data data set
prescriptions so now go into a little
bit more detail about these points of
view and why intake exists and how it's
supposed to solve these problems so here
is a data scientist or at least this is
what google image search tells me a data
scientist looks like those of you that
are data scientist I'm sure you draw
graphs and things all the time and and
whatever geometry stuff is going on here
they their main concern a
is what are my data sets of those which
one has the characteristics that meets
the job that I now need to do and then
how do I actually go about getting hold
of that so that I can get on with my job
the data users job is to take that data
and do something with it their job is
not to figure all that stuff out so you
already saw this is the same cell again
in the intake world it becomes a
one-liner which is good
you also get some additional
functionality for example this GUI which
I will demonstrate to you in a live demo
which hopefully runs it's not much live
code has been at this conference so
you'll actually get to see some within
your catalogs you should be able to
search you should be able to for each of
your data entries get information about
what it is what it what data shape it
has various things like that we have
built in plotting so that you can get
quick plots that you design or there may
be some predefined quick plots that
demonstrate what the data is about and
of course the one-line loading from the
providers point of view they care about
making data available getting it to the
users they need to know what data they
have internally and they need to be able
to describe their internal data sources
anyway so they're already doing some of
this somehow and many companies have
solved this or partially solved this
problem many times over so here's an
opportunity for doing it in a structured
way that we can all take part in
standardized and most importantly the
data provided needs to be able to get
the user to be able to do what the user
does and we're going to encode things
using intake and pass that to the user
and that's done like this so here is an
actual llamó prescription of a data set
this is just purely for example and it's
something that looks pretty simple this
is actually a fairly complicated version
of one you have some sources we have one
that is called first data entry it's
going to be read by
thing called CSV it has some risk some
description it has some user parameters
those are things that we can actually
allow the user to choose between in this
case whether they want part 1 or part 2
arbitrary metadata we can encode all of
the important information about your
data goes in there and actual arguments
that are going to be passed to a Python
function that Python function in this
case is just going to read CSV and we
probably already know how to do that and
that's it so this gets written into a
file that file is shared with the user
it can be literally given to the user
but probably you want to put it into
some centralized place on s3 or whatever
and then you can change the catalog the
user doesn't know the user just loads
the latest data every time they don't
need to know how this process works IT
again they care about security about
granting access about monitoring who's
touching what about authenticating how
those people actually get into the
system and critically this last one is
important for many organizations they
actually want to be the gatekeepers of
data that's coming into the system so in
the intake world they can have opinions
about how credentials are passed around
here is another llamó catalog in this
case the data is stored on s3 for
example and you're going to provide
username and password to be able to
access it and this particular
prescription you don't need to care too
much about how these details actually
work for the time being but you have a
user parameter here which is going to
fill in the username automatically using
environment variables or other
mechanisms there are other possibilities
but it's still going to require the user
name to pass their password at runtime
that's one possibility there are lots of
possibilities so these hooks exist for
IT to be able to ensure that things are
getting from the environment or from the
user into the system without having to
hard-code them into scripts also there
is an intake server so you can host
these catalogs not a spy
else butts as an endpoint that the user
can touch and then you can control how
authentication happens with HTTP HTTP
headers or java web tokens or whatever
is the right thing for you you can also
run your server as a data streaming
service and not just the data
definitions but the data itself you can
get keep there and that means you have
all the opportunities or authentication
and monitoring that you might want to do
so that's that's all convenient
I expect we have probably fewer people
who are at this end of things but you
can ask me about how this stuff works
afterwards and then finally the
developer this doesn't look too much
like me but again Google tells me that
this is what a programmer looks like you
see has been very short sighted quite
hunch okay fine
hold on I'll do that too so the
developer doesn't want to rewrite stuff
that already exists out there they want
to use code that is good at loading data
into memory but they want the framework
to put this within they don't want to
have to rewrite all the hooks - oh how
do I connect to this data store all
these things should be in a consistent
framework and the API that is presented
to the user should always be the same
you don't want to have to teach your
user each time you write a piece of code
how do I go about using that particular
piece of code that's really annoying and
finally you could submit your latest
loading function to pandas or numpy or
whatever is appropriate for that
particular type of data but actually
it's a pretty slow process so intake
provides a mechanism to get loading code
out into the wild pretty easily and this
is what some intake code might actually
look like this is a real data driver
from a tutorial so it's not particularly
complicated but in this case it connects
to github and it views a set of issues
on a particular repo in github as a data
set
and this goes to show that I'm not just
talking about files now I'm talking
about data services that can provide
things that you can think of as a data
set it's pretty short you don't have to
write many methods and when you do this
then you get all the cataloging features
of intake and actually quite a few
features along the way as well so those
are built into intake intake itself is
pretty easy to extend it has lots of
points for with plug-in architecture so
you can add to it as a developer so
those that are interested in intake as a
project rather than just as a thing to
use then I want to see you on github
contributing tomorrow maybe I'm going to
switch now to some live code I made it
yeah okay so I have two notebooks that I
will fairly quickly go through I want to
leave plenty of time at the end for
questions and discussion so I'll make
this pretty quick one of the things that
was on a slide but I didn't explicitly
mention yet is the intake gives you the
opportunity to install data using
khandha so this line I have run already
and when you've done that then you have
this built in catalog that includes now
some entries this is rate various types
of crime within the US over a time
period
so having done kondeh install my data I
can now access the data so it's it's
there I have an entry in this in this
built-in catalog called US crime I can
get information about it it has some
basic description this is the same API
as a user would go through for whatever
kind of catalog they're connecting to I
can get more information about this so
discover is now actually reading some
part of the data and I have a set of D
types again this is a panda's data frame
as it happens data frames are very
common but not the only option you'll
also notice that down here this has a
thing called plots so in this particular
case just for example
sake there is an automatic plotting spec
built into the actual data description
so this is a hint to the user that this
particular plot name is a useful thing
to look at if you're interested in using
this data it just shows these two these
are two columns in the original data and
apparently 1981 was a bad time if you
had valuables in your house for some
reason those of you that are history
students maybe know what was going on
there I don't and then there's the the
one-liner
which is again now you just do read and
now it's a data frame and you can do
usual data frame like things to it
which I want other showing you but I
will show you the GUI so this is the
first GUI and a simplest GUI probably we
will have some more standalone things
also in the future this shows the same
built in dataset that you saw above with
its details here on the right and I can
again access it using discover but I can
also load more catalogs using this GUI
you can of course do this in code as
well so let me find my examples and I'll
just load one of them for you this by
the way is using Jupiter widgets which I
found really nice to get going with and
to produce something simple enough to
use here so that's a little catalog so
I've done that and the catalog appears
here and it has some entries in it again
I can page through these and I can get
information about them one interesting
thing about this particular test catalog
is that it includes a reference to
another catalog so these things can be
hierarchical and you can build that so
the the catalog is itself a data source
you can have catalogs that include other
catalogs so you can master catalog that
you can see how that can be a very
useful thing also you can
include remote so we'll find out now if
the Wi-Fi is still working so here we
have this is the data catalog that's
currently used in production by the
Pangaea collaboration these are various
scientific data sets so meteorological
ensemble of stuff I gather this is not
my speciality but people are using this
now and the point of it is that you can
seamlessly point to online resources
whether it's HTTP or s3 or Google or
Azure or whatever all of these four
things work and frequently if you're
doing that then the data itself will
also be stored in those cloud locations
so that you can seamlessly get your user
access to data that exists out there and
they don't need to worry about plumbing
through the various connectors to be
able to make that happen
okay swapping across to my second demo
if your data engineer that is you are
interested in making catalogs then this
is how you would go about doing that so
I'm not going to talk about the dev part
of actually writing drivers for intake
or talking about enhancing intake itself
I'll just talk about the two kinds of
intake users that I mentioned earlier
intake comes with some built-in drivers
for various data types there's also a
whole slew of other add-ons that you can
install I'll show you those in a moment
if you wanted to investigate how do I go
about making a catalog for something you
might start like this so for each of
these drivers there is an intake dot
open function and you can read the duct
strings of that function and figure out
how it works in this case this is yet
another CSV and I all I need to do to
read this es CSV is to pass it a URL it
could be something that's more
complicated obviously CSVs can have a
number of problems
or the data formats may have lots of
options that you would care about this
is the simplest case so I defined it and
I can do discover and I can see that
this passes fine it has three columns
and I can actually read the data so this
source thing is behaves exactly like one
of the entries within a catalog except
that it's not in a catalog I'm just
using it for discovery sake I can also
plot it so this is just showing you a
plot you could play around with this a
lot to figure out what set of keyword
arguments here really demonstrates the
features of your data set HP far is very
nice for those that haven't come across
it
this is hollow views bouquet all of
these things plug together very nicely
and it's a built-in feature of intake to
be able to do this okay so the point of
all of this is that we have this data
source and we can mate
yamo automatically that describes what
we just did above all it really contains
is a driver so it's the CSV and an
argument if we had more arguments than
they would all appear here and this is a
nice stub that you can put within one of
your young on catalogs here is a
slightly more fleshed-out version of the
same thing as above now has a
description now it includes the same
plot as I had so this now I put into a
llamo file I open that llamo file and I
can plot it again I just called the plot
basic up here the point of doing it is
to show you that the llamo file now does
exactly the same thing as I had just
discovered before so I'm going to look
at my data figure out how to load it and
code it in the llamo file this is now
ready to pass off to a user you might do
that by posting it in github for example
or just or anywhere that you have access
to which can include s3 or whatever you
like so if you post it there now you can
load it from remote and again you can do
exactly the same thing so now we have
the data except the
it's coming from somewhere else this is
in practice the thing that you can pass
to your user and it's the easiest way to
get them loading your data so if you're
starting off with intake and you want to
make catalogs this is probably how you
would go about it at least to start off
with later you can get into making
Condor packages and and all that kind of
stuff
and then the final interesting thing as
I mentioned before the catalog itself is
also a data entry it looks like this and
you can include this within other
catalogs if you want to okay so that's
it for demonstration I'm going to leave
a good ten odd minutes for discussion at
the end but I did promise you that I
would show you the state of the drivers
that currently exist this is actually a
set of repos each of these repos
contains at least one driver some of
them contain more this is the website
for a general documentation about and
taken this directory is on there this is
already out of date so we have people
that are contributing to this list
currently and I encourage you to
consider the kind of data that you're
interested in if it's not on the list do
make that bit of code that is going to
intake if I your existing data loading
practices you'll notice that quite a
number of these are not files but a data
services of some kind which is
interesting
so intake is really about unifying not
just data loading but data services some
of them can actually be data catalogs
themselves so intake which is fairly
simple easy to understand code base can
be the unifying umbrella that brings
these things together it again now this
is my summary slide so I just take you
through point by point intake provides
consistent simple API for users it
provides the cataloguing system you can
use the amel syntax it's very simple you
can get going but there are other ways
to do that too you separate out the
people that
prescribed what the data is where it
lives how to load it from the user who
just now gets to load their data without
worrying about anything else you can
access remote data both for the catalogs
and for the data itself or remote data
services there is a plug-in system you
can produce these things very easily
both the loaders and various other parts
of the intake system there is the server
for those that really want to lock up
their infrastructure and again talk
about that separately and importantly
for this crowd it plugs in to various
other elements of the PI data ecosystem
the GUI was running in Jupiter obviously
HV plot was being used to display those
automatic quick plots you can come to
install stuff all of this exists on
Condor I work for anaconda so I have to
say that most of the data types also
interact very nicely with tasks because
I'm also working on desk so I care about
that it means that for bigger than
memory data sets you can load using desk
if you want to it's optional you don't
have to use desk but it does work well
and then finally again a call to
everybody this here please try intake
and let me know what you think the
installation is this line here you can
come to get hub and raise issues or
provide pull requests please very
welcome documentation and general
chatter on geta so that leaves plenty of
time and you can shout out questions or
come to the microphones and we can start
talking
can you can you do a compare and
contrast with Apache Atlas I don't
actually know how Atlas works there are
lots of pieces of software out there
that do some of what intake does and I
used to have a comparison slide in this
talk to show what I viewed us their main
focus Atlas was not on that slide but
lots of other things were and so maybe
you can tell me a little bit about how
this works because I died I simply don't
know that but intake is meant to be
simple enough for everybody to get
engaged it really is a PI data focused
thing the question was in the case where
you have data coming in on a regular
time table and you want to be able to
access both the most recent as a as a
thing and separately the set of
historical data sets
there isn't a built-in mechanism to do
that but you could encode it very easily
there is the concept of user parameters
for example so the default could be
latest but the allowed set of things
that you could choose could be all of
the currently existing months that that
would be a pretty simple way to do that
do I have to download my data every time
I have a feeling I know why you ask that
the question okay so do I have to
download my data every time as I said
intake comes with a number of freebies
that make working with data a little bit
easier one particular contribution by
somebody whose name I can't quite
remember was a cache on the first access
mechanism so you can choose to have this
as part of your data definition the
first time a user actually wants to read
your CSV or whatever file type it may be
intake will download it and keep a local
copy of it so that all subsequent reads
will happen much faster obviously some
data types lend themselves to this being
useful other data types not necessarily
and it's going to depend on whether you
expect your user to be working from
their workstation or whether this is
something that's in the cloud but it's a
it's a very nice option to have
available to you and this is a decision
that's made by the catalog author on
whether this particular data set is
appropriate for being cached or not or
the freebies that we've had added
recently is finally in passing came in
about a month ago I think which allows
you to use the information that's
encoded in in the path and file name of
each of the pieces of your data set
often people encode useful information
there and you want that to be loaded too
you want that to be part of your data
rather than some side code that tries to
figure out for each part of your data
set where did it come from
don't be shiny yes so excuse me so just
to clarify when intake reads a file
intake is itself reading the file then
passes it to something like pandas so if
pandas could read something but intake
can't
then intake wouldn't be able to pass
something off to pandas is that correct
actually intake is simply calling the
same function that you could have called
yourself intake is handling the
prescription of what set of parameters
to pass to that function okay someone up
top I'm coming I didn't see each tier 5
as one of the drivers because they're a
new work done on that there is the
intake x-ray plug-in has all of the
methods available to accelerate to load
netcdf like things which includes at
least array oriented hdf5 if you wanted
to write an HD f5 tabular reader that
would be very simple to do but it
doesn't exist yet the question was can
intake work with spark and as it happens
there is a new repo which has not been
released yet but that code is already in
place at least at a starting level to
enable you to do the same thing for
spark so in this case you would encode
the set of parameters that you're going
to give spark but you can put that into
a catalog again so you can use intake to
catalog the set of things that you would
like to load using spark now you
probably won't
in that case want to do a dot to read to
get the whole thing in memory because
the whole point of spark is to be able
to handle much larger data sets than
that you you can exist at a function but
there will also be a to spark method
which will give you the handle to the
spark RDD or data frame which again is
the thing that your end user wants to be
able to do their work with
we don't take care of setting up a
context for you so this assumes that you
already know how to connect to some spot
cluster somewhere okay it sounds like
we're we've run out of questions so I
will leave it there and you can find me
later to talk about intake and desk and
anaconda in general
[Music]